hey i'm dion robon i'm a markets
reporter for the wall street journal and
i want to talk to you a little bit about
a story that i think hasn't been getting
nearly enough attention that's about the
rising value of the dollar the dollar
rose by seven percent last year that was
its strongest year since 2015. so here's
why the dollar is rising and how that
increase in the value of the dollar
could have a major impact on the value
of the stock market let's get into it so
why is the dollar getting stronger
well it starts with the rebound that
we've seen in the u.s economy in 2021
the us added around 6 million jobs the
other big piece the economic puzzle is
gross domestic product gdp usgdp is
expected to grow around six percent for
2021 that's the best year we've had in
quite some time now all that matters to
the dollar because the value of the
dollar is reflective of again the us
economy people want to put their money
in a place where they know it's going to
be safe and a place in an economy that
they think is going to grow and when
more people want to put money in dollars
it makes the value of the dollar rise
having a strong economy is great but
what really draws the value of foreign
money to the us and the u.s dollar
is high treasury yields now i know what
you're thinking the u.s treasury yields
are historically low but if we compare
them to other industrialized and
developed nations well the value of u.s
treasury yields is very high that drives
a lot of money from outside the u.s into
the u.s when i talk to one of my
long-time sources john doyle he's the
vice president of trading and dealing at
tempest inc he tells me that the biggest
factor has been the hawkish turn by the
federal reserve to fight persistent
inflation here in the u.s the fed is
expected to hike interest rates faster
than most other central banks this year
that's going to in theory at least raise
the value of u.s treasury yields and
make the dollar even more attractive as
a place for foreigners to store their
money in the u.s so why could this be a
problem for the stock market
well let's think about it experts agree
corporate profits are the biggest driver
of stock prices and u.s companies have
increased their overseas presence in
recent years and in fact s p 500
companies generated 40 percent of their
revenue from outside the us according to
factset now those other countries
they've got other currencies and when
the value of the dollar rises the value
of those currencies declines now usually
prices stay pretty stable so if the
price of something isn't rising
but its value in dollar terms is
declining
that means companies are making less
money think about it like this if
something cost 100 euros and you were
getting 120 for every euro but now
you're getting 110 well that thing is
still being sold for 100 euros but you
as an american company are only getting
a hundred ten dollars
that's a loss this is what happens when
the value of the dollar rises the
dollar's seven percent gain in 2021
basically reversed its entire loss for
2020 so if we're back where we were in
2019 we're back at a place where the
strong dollar is hurting companies and
hurting international sales lower sales
equals lower profits which could drag
down stock prices if this continues into
2022 you can expect to hear more
executives complaining about the strong
dollar now add to that supply chain
bottlenecks inflation and a federal
reserve that instead of cutting rates
and making conditions easier is making
things tighter and you can see why the
strong dollar could have a real impact
on the stock market
if you enjoyed this video make sure and
hit the like button and if you're
interested in markets and you want to
watch and learn more be sure and
subscribe to keep up with my latest as
the west coast rapper sugarfree once
said if you stay ready you ain't got to
get ready
thanks for watching i'll see you next
time